[Music]
the creatures and monsters of Greek
mythology are something that we've
covered in some detail but there are
some minor ones that are yet to have
their own video so today's video will be
on lad on the hundred headed serpent
also known as the Hesperian dragon some
of you may recognize the name because
Ladon was the beast tossed by the
goddess Hera with garden the golden
apples that grew in the garden of the
Hesperides when Heracles came to collect
the apples as part of his 12 labors he
killed the serpent who would then be
placed amongst the stars as the
constellation Draco the dragon there are
of course versions of this story where
Heracles convinced the Titan atlas to
collect the apples for him and then this
timeline I guess we can assume that
Ladin doesn't actually die but in the
iteration where it is in fact slain
Jason and the Argonauts come across it's
still twitchy embody the very next day
and they're told by the Hesperides that
a man with a bow killed the snake that
guards the tree and bought them grave
sorrow this is interesting because there
are accounts of Ladin being described as
immortal but that doesn't necessarily
mean that it cannot be slain the man of
the bow was of course Heracles and the
fact that he used his bow means that it
would have taken the poisonous blood of
the Hydra to kill Adam the Hesperides
described in the death of Ladin as
bringing them grave sorrow in a way
gives us an insight into the
relationship between them it gives us
the idea that Ladon was intelligent
enough to distinguish between the
Hesperides and those trying to steal the
apples from the garden and there are
even some descriptions while i don't is
able to speak and communicate in several
different voices and tones so maybe it
wasn't as wild as the Chimera or the
Hydra but that certainly doesn't mean
you could just walk into the garden and
have a friendly conversation
the Greek historian dia Doris actually
interpreted Ladon as a human shepherd
who guarded a flock of Golden Fleece
sheep the sheep was said to have been a
color unlike anything seen before and
many trying to steal the flock for
themselves but the Shepherd was able to
fend them all off with a noticeable
strength implying that Ladin may not
have been entirely human
Theodorus does also note then everyone
is free to form their own opinion on
this story as there are quite a few
conflicting ideas the apples in the
Sheep may not have been golden coins or
treasure but they certainly would have
fetched a fair price for anyone who
obtained them in this entire notion of
dragons and serpents guarding gold and
things of value is actually something we
see across numerous cultures all around
the world most commonly it's described
as the offspring of echidna and - which
does make sense considering that they
are the mother and father of monsters
but in some conflicting accounts
Madden's parents and siblings are said
to represent the dangers of the sea with
the word Ladon thought to mean strong
flow in this case Ladon originates from
where many of the other deities and
creatures of the sea came from four seas
and Seto borrowing the story of Heracles
and Jason and his Argonauts we don't
really see none anywhere else if you'd
like to share your opinion on which
story or version of laDawn that you
prefer then feel free to do so in the
comments below if you have enjoyed the
video then please consider leaving a
thumbs up as it really does help me and
the channel as always I've been your
host ethology and fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]